Mac OS Ventura has finally been released
and with it came a brand new genius
feature from Apple why buy another
really expensive webcam for your web
conferencing if you don't like the
built-in webcam like the 1080p one on
the 16-inch MacBook Pro what you could
simply use your iPhone's webcam which is
by far better than any other webcam you
can find anywhere I mean this is killer
and the best part about it is that every
time you upgrade your iPhone to a new
one your webcam basically gets even
better and of course I'm talking about
the brand new continuity camera feature
that Apple showed off in June at WWDC
and it is finally released and official
so in this video I'm going to go through
a setup and a tutorial guide including
all the different settings and
everything else you need to know to use
continuity camera so let's jump right
into it you can see on my display right
here it says use iPhone as a webcam of
course I already have Mac OS Ventura
installed right here and it says
continue with the camera lets your
iPhone be a webcam for your Mac when
both devices are near each other which I
have it right here it automatically
connects which is awesome you have your
visual effects even your desk view which
I'm going to show you guys so let's hit
continue so getting right into it I have
photo booth open right here which is a
good app to kind of show the webcam and
as you can see the quality is pretty bad
it's honestly not too great so let's
test out continuity camera now check out
how easy it is to turn this on you
literally just go up to the camera tab
in the menu bar you can see it's set to
FaceTime HD camera all you got to do is
click on the iPhone camera right here
and watch it switch hey there you go wow
that quality is insane that is
incredibly good camera quality look at
that now of course you're not going to
be holding your iPhone while doing a Web
Conference you've got to mount it
somehow to basically the top of your
MacBook and that is why you're going to
need some sort of accessory like moff's
new laptop phone holder which basically
connects to the top of your MacBook you
basically can flip it out to the side or
you can go up so let me show you how
easy it is let me first use this little
sticker to attach it to the MacBook now
the goal of getting this mounted
correctly is to put it in the corner of
your Macbook so that way you can flip it
out like this to mount your iPhone on
the side or you can flip it up like that
to use for continuity camera so all you
got to do is simply take the little
adhesive protector off there you go we
have our sticker flip it over line it up
and stick it on there you go apply some
pressure make sure it's stuck on good
and one thing I really like is the clean
moff logo on the back with this nice
vegan leather texture and now that it's
set up all you do is you grab it from
the back flip it over and then Mount
your iPhone right on the side like this
and I do recommend using a Max save
compatible case to make the magnetic
strength A Little Bit Stronger like
moff's snap case right here and there
you go you have like a secondary iPhone
display which you can use let's say
browse Twitter whatever while you're
working on your MacBook for example or
of course you can mount it on the other
side if you want to which you usually
wouldn't do because for continuity
camera we actually want to use it just
like this you flip up the phone holder
and then you can mount your iPhone like
this again as a secondary display but
now in widescreen view so that you can
let's say watch some videos or movies
while you're working but we're actually
going to flip it to the other side just
like that and now we have our iPhone set
up facing us giving us awesome
continuity camera quality literally the
best webcam you can get so with that
said you'll find a link to moth's laptop
phone holder down in the description and
pinned comment below but now getting
back into the continuity camera tutorial
and guide as you can see we say it back
up and now check this out this quality
comparison between the actual webcam on
the 16 inch MacBook Pro which is now
better it's 1080p with really good
software and the new ISP and you can
tell that the quality is so much better
you literally can't beat it and once
again let me mention that every time you
upgrade your iPhone you're getting a
webcam upgrade with continuity camera
which makes it so amazing and worth it
compared to spending a couple hundred
dollars or more on an actual Pro 4k
camera or webcam but now with that said
let's jump back into FaceTime which is
where a lot of people are actually going
to use this other apps like Zoom Google
meets whatever you want to use once
again we go to that video Tab and click
on the iPhone camera bam we get a huge
increase in quality that is just insane
let's do a quick little face time and
there you go you can see that we have
our little FaceTime window right here
and you can actually click this little
button for the background blur effects
which using the actual iPhone camera
makes this so much more clean and
accurate compared to using the webcam I
mean it looks amazing you blur out your
background but the really cool thing is
the new desk view which you can just
click that button right there and it's
going to pop it up whoa look at that
okay so let's share the desk view wow
this is weird look
if you have it set up like this it could
literally be showing stuff off or like
your keyboard whatever desk you that
looks pretty cool actually if you want
to show something or anything else bam
I'm surprised this works so well using
the ultra wide camera
and then you could actually zoom in more
it's kind of weird oh there you go look
at that that is zoomed out quite a lot
that's cool that you can do that let's
show some stuff off hey I mean like I
guess there are some use cases where
this is actually very useful and wow
it's cool you probably wouldn't want it
that zoomed in so look at that we have
these little FaceTime settings where you
can change the shared view share the
entire screen now even better you could
actually switch to using your iPhone's
microphones instead of the built-in ones
inside of your Macbook so I'll just go
up to the video Tab and you can see
right here just go into Max's iPhone
microphone right there and now it is
using it for the audio that's going to
be useful if let's say you have an older
MacBook but still Mac OS Ventura but the
microphones are not that great
especially on some older MacBooks
compared to let's say you just got a
brand new iPhone with killer microphones
you're gonna get much better quality out
of your iPhone's mics and now I know
with this corner set up for the mop tone
holder you could have it kind of off to
the side if you want the display view or
you can have it like this and it's a
little bit off balance in terms of not
being centered with the MacBook but of
course you could also ticket right here
on the back for a more direct view so if
you wanted a perfectly centered image
you just basically grab your iPhone with
a moft holder on it line it up to be
perfectly where you would like it and
then kind of save that spot
and stick it right there and there you
go using it with this method we have a
perfectly centered image just like with
your regular webcam this is the way I
would probably do it if I really wanted
to use continuity camera all the time
with the great video quality just look
at that that is amazing so basically
there you guys go that's continuity
camera using your iPhone and mops phone
holder this is basically the best way to
do it if you want the absolute greatest
webcam quality of course let me remind
you you have to have Mac OS Ventura so
that's available now go ahead and
download it test out this feature it
basically Works automatically you just
go up into the video Tab and choose your
iPhone camera that is it that's super
convenient and I think this is probably
the best webcam you can buy so go ahead
and check out mom's phone holder down in
the description and pinned comment below
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]